hi i'm eric voss an avengers in game is
now available digitally in places other
than my tear-soaked memories allowing
nerds to actually re-watch this movie
frame by
frame and if you're like me and i am so
sorry if that's the case
you probably directed your rewatch
attention to that epic final battle
it is filled with interesting cameos
easter eggs callbacks many of which i
got when we first watched the movie but
now
that we can really zoom and enhance on
all this stuff let us re-watch the
in-game final battle for all the new
details that we missed the first time
there's a lot of stuff hidden visual
clues interesting combat moves and
assists
hidden layers of meaning there's way
more than i ever realized spoiler
warning for all things mcu passed and if
i accidentally say something happens in
mcu future okay starting in this final
battle notice
when the mcu trinity make their initial
approach to thanos
as he waits for them in the rubble of
avengers hq thanos holds a handful of
stones
debris from the rubble now it's hard to
get an accurate count of these because
the camera cuts away from his hand when
he starts to flick them to the ground
but it looks as though thanos is holding
six of those stones
as if he's visualizing holding all six
infinity stones in his hand
applying i guess that secret
visualization mindset to this coming
stones battle remember this thanos is
from 2014
a time before he conceived of a gauntlet
as a way to contain all six stones at
once thinking about the timeline itri
probably wouldn't have forged that for
him until sometime between
2015 and 2017 depending on when you
think that age voltron post credit scene
took place
and whether the gauntlet and odin's
vault was indeed not legit
okay then the fight begins and right
away thor proved he has learned from his
past mistakes
his first strikes against thanos with
mjolnir and then again with stormbreaker
booth go for the head just as he did in
the opening beheading
thanos blocks iron man and thor's duo
power up blast by twirling his blade
which some have interpreted as a nod
possibly to the thanos copter
that was the goofy yellow helicopter
that thanos flew in a 1979 spider-man
comic was turned into a toy
by mattel and kind of a meme fans have
been petitioning for it to appear in the
mcu
this apparently is the closest we'll get
and we will take it another interesting
detail to point out about this
three on one fight is how it displays
the relative strength between the
avengers like when thanos hits cap
cap goes flying but when thanos hits
thor a god
thor takes a hit but mostly absorbs it
maybe it's all that insulation now one
of the more interesting moments we've
been wondering about
occurred right before the big cap
wielding millionaire moment thanos is
fighting thor
thor summons stormbreaker but thanos
intercepts it
he swings it upward and then pushes it
closer and closer into thor's chest
now this is a callback to thor doing
this to thanos and infinity war but also
it somewhat suggests that thanos might
be worthy of stormbreaker and mjolnir
now that's just a theory i would say
it's possible that thanos just might be
redirecting the battle axes kinetic
energy just a bit
rather than like lifting it also we
should say that most of the deeds that
thanos commits to
prove his worth so to speak applied to
the thanos of infinity war the 2018
thanos not
this thanos who is younger from 2014 and
less of an eco-terrorist seeking balance
than a straight-up genocidal fatalist
seeking to burn everything so even if
there is a version of thanos who is
worthy
i don't think this moment proves this
thanos to be so
meanwhile just be clear cap lifting
mjolnir was intended to establish him as
always worthy when thor says i knew it
it's a deliberate call back to age of
ultron when cap tried to lift the hammer
and it budged ever so slightly
the directors confirmed that cap in that
moment knew he could lift mjolnir if he
wanted but he decided to spare thor's
pride
cap shows off his mastery with mjolnir
when he tosses his shield past
thanos and then deflects mjolnir off his
own shield
creating a shockwave that knocks thanos
to his feet cap
is recreating that team-up move that he
and thor did in the beginning of age of
ultron
after this initial beat down by cap
thanos frustrated
removes his helmet and delivers a
vicious volley in response
it's almost as if his helmet was getting
in his way so he removed it for round
two of this boxing match
and when cap tries to hit thanos again
with mjolnir thanos grabs cap's wrist
not mjolnir's handle or mural near
itself perhaps this is another clue
pointing to thanos not being worthy cap
gets knocked to the ground
shields split in half the imagery of cap
defeated like this
evokes tony's nightmare vision in the
age of ultron and for tony if you think
about it
this darkest moment shows that nightmare
coming true
natasha's death the return of leviathans
the directors are returning to that
imagery to make
us feel complete despair here now while
all this is going on underground a few
interesting new details have emerged
as the other avengers get their bearings
in the rubble ant-man radios to hulk
rhodian rocket behind scott
is actually roadie's new redlined war
machine armor
roadie shows up wearing this later in
the battle but here they established how
scott was able to get roadie in this new
armor so quickly
and when hawkeye's getting stalked by
the crawling outriders in the tunnel it
fires an arrow that lights up the tunnel
reveals them it's a bit of a nod to that
shot in
aliens which is a favorite of the russos
that got referenced in infinity war when
hicks shines a light into the darkness
and dozens of crawling xenomorphs are
there now the battle reaches its
climactic turning point when doctor
strange and the sorcerers portal in the
heroes and warriors from across the
universe including the ravagers and
howard the duck
actually kraglin with yondu's yaka arrow
headpiece was supposed to be among them
but removed from the film and the portal
through which the ravagers and howard
the duck arrive if you look closely at
that background
is contraxia that's the snow-covered
planet that they were all hanging out in
and guardians voting too now during this
charge it's kind of fun to figure out
what spider-man is swinging from
initially he gets an assist from scott's
giant hand
very cool but later in the wide overhead
shot peter's just kind of floating on
nothing
in the front line maybe the clouds or
invisible helicopters from that
spider-man ps2 game oh if you look
closely he might be swinging from falcon
or part of thanos's fleet and then
lots of fun moves appear in that initial
collision between the lines
cap underhand throws milner into coal
obsidian thor lightning plows a group
scott lang punches a leviathan drax
jumps on kolb city and from behind and
stabs his shoulders with his daggers
he's doing this to free korg from
headlock shortly after this there's
another move that i missed before
as cap and thor trades stormbreaker and
mjolnir behind them
mantis brings down a beast by putting it
in a trance and there are a bunch of
other moments i pointed out before like
stark and peter parker finally getting
that hug that peter wanted in spider-man
homecoming stark denied him saying we're
not there yet now they are
also falcons stabs someone with his
wingtips so cool
and hope van dyne radios to cap we're on
it cap
the knowing look that scott gives her a
call back to that scene and ant-man the
wasp when hope mocked him for this
it was a matter of national security the
cap needed help
ten america captain cap
it's it's what we call them but some new
details have emerged here the filmmakers
have said after the movie came out that
they intended
more reunion moments between characters
in this final battle but i had to cut
them for time and you can actually see a
glimpse of one
right behind scott and hope here groot
extends his branches
up to slam down an enemy who's coming up
behind rocket now later we see how
rocket returns the favor by covering
groot when thanos reigns fire on the
battlefield there's also a
kind of hilarious missable continuity
error here scott and hope go into the
quantum tunnel van trying to jump start
it
but shortly after this giant scott is
visible in the background shoving a
leviathan into a portal and then after
that shot scott and hope are back in the
van normal size yeah i guess it's
possible that
after we cut away from scott he could
have taken a break from jump starting
the van
growing big again and then pushed this
leviathan into hell and then
shrunk back down to normal size to
continue jump starting the van or this
is all just a montage and some stuff is
out of chronological sequence or we'll
just have to consider that the most
profitable film of all time screwed
something up
it is possible don't get me started
about those damn pin particles cap gives
spider-man an assist with mjolnir has
something to hijack from
and he calls him queens i'll call back
to their exchange in civil war
you got hard kid where you from
queens brooklyn and during the final
charge with the female heroes okoye is
the one to impale corvus glaive perhaps
giving her some closure
after corvus killed many of the door
melanche guards in the battle of wakanda
and during thanos melee with captain
marvel thanos
rips the power stone out of the gauntlet
and punches her with it the purple
energy consumes his hand and
arm just like it did with peter quill
and the others in the first guardians
movie but
unlike those others thanos is strong
enough to wield the stone
in his bare hand alone and then the
moment our hearts stopped thanos
nearly snaps but listen closely to the
music
that music sting there is actually the
same music
that we heard all the way back in the
first avengers the similarly
heart-stopping moment that iron man flew
the nuke through the portal
come on storm
composer alan silvestri resamples this
dramatic light motif
to bring us back to that feeling of
nearly losing everything
but saved at the last second by papa
tony dionysus forces dust away and it's
a kind of creepy cathartic parallel to
the tragic ending of infinity war
like leviathan dusts away right as it
chomps down on rocket and it releases a
haunting scream
and i pointed this out before but the
way each of thanos's black order dusts
away
reflects some of the avengers dust
moments ebony maw
dusts as he limps up to thanos clutching
his chest just as peter parker did on
titan
and proxima midnight dusts away with
husband corvus glaive and her arms
posed the exact same way scarlet witch
was with vision and wakanda
oh just kidding i feel nothing thanos
meanwhile is left
empty gauntleted returning him back to
his empty gauntlet status from that age
of ultron post credits scene
that started his whole stone quest and
his final breaths are shown
in the exact same camera movement as his
final shot infinity war
dollying around the mad titan as he
limps sits
and reflects now there is one more
possible easter egg that
a lot of people have been talking about
showing up in peter parker's high school
in the closing montage there is a girl
with short blonde hair
a pink backpack and a web pattern on her
skirt
which many are saying could be guin
agustasi
now marvel has not confirmed this and
they probably will never because gwen
stacy is technically a sony property
and any appearance of the character in
the mcu would have to be a huge
complicated negotiation so this student
is likely just one of the many
spider-man fans
at peter parker's high school whom we
can just call gwen stacy don't tell sony
comment down below with your favorite
new detail that you spotted from your
avengers in-game rewatch that i know you
definitely did
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos and subscribe to new rockstars
breakdowns and theories about everything
marvel
thank you for joining me and now it's
just the first two hours of this movie
to
re-watch frame by frame
kill me
[Music]
you